The way that we write JavaScript
applications is changing.
Previously, what we would do is
have maybe a couple of script
tags in the body of our document,
and maybe load in jQuery in our
own JavaScript, or maybe we had
a build process where we would
concatenate and minify all of
JavaScript together. However,
with ES6, it's starting to
become popular to pick up what's
called JavaScript modules. Now,
this is not new to JavaScript,
however, with ES6 we're seeing
everybody sort of uptake it.
What is a JavaScript module?
It's essentially just a file
with one or many functions
inside of it and then you can
make those functions available
to other files. You can make
those functions available to
other applications. You can also
use people's existing modules.
Instead of using a script tag
and having a whole bunch of
global variables, what we do is
we import things from existing
modules. Right here, I've got
three import statements where
maybe I need a slug library.
Instead of finding one and using
a script tag, I did an npm
install -- we'll look at how to
do that -- and I import slug
from slug. Maybe you're using a
utility library, like Lodash,
and you need to pull in a couple
of the methods that you
explicitly need here in a unique
shuffle. I'm
just importing those two things.
I'm cherry-picking them in.
Maybe you're using a slider plug
where you need to import
Flickity, import it from the
package that is called Flickity.
That is JavaScript modules. We
are going to dive into how this
all works, the tooling of all it
works, how we can create our own
named exports versus default
exports. It's a pretty big topic
to cover, but I think this is
really crucial to understanding
how to write modern JavaScript.
Everything we've been doing so
far, we've been simply writing
it in a HTML file and opening it
up in the browser. That's
because ES6 has fantastic
support across all the browsers.
The one thing where support is
really lacking, and we're sort
of seeing browser vendors look
at how they're going to
implement it, is ES6 modules. We
do need some tooling in order to
actually start using the syntax
and using the idea of importing
and exporting modules. What we
need to do is, first, set up a
package adjacent file, which is
going to let us install our
external dependencies from npm,
and then we're also going to
need to use Webpack, which is
going to bundle up all of our
JavaScript together. If I
import a couple libraries, I
export a couple things, and I
have maybe seven or eight files,
it's going to bundle it up into
a single or multiple files for
me. What we want to do here is...
I am in the JavaScript modules
and using npm folder. What I
want to do is then create a
second folder inside of that.
I'm going to type M-K-D-I-R,
mkdir. You can do this via your
Winder OL. I'm going to say
mkdir ES6 modules. I'm going to
go into ES6 modules. Triple-
check you are in the right
folder. You should be in a file
called ES6 modules. Again, I did
not give you that. You should
create that yourself. Then we
need to start things off. Now,
there are lots of ways to get
modules. There is Bower and
there's something called jspm.
But the pretty standard way to
do it and what has won out is
called npm. You probably have
stumbled upon npm before and
that's what we're going to use
to install all of our
dependencies. What we need to
do is first create ourselves an
entry point. I like to call this
app.js. I'll say touch, app.js.
Let's see what we got. We just
have a app.js file so far. Then
we need to initialize an npm
package.json, so you just say
npm init. It's going to ask you
a series of questions here in
terms of what would you like to
call it. You can go ahead and
fill this out to be whatever you
want. Really there is not any
information that you need to put
in so you can just hit Enter as
you go on through. We're going
to go back into that package.
json. If you actually take a
look here you'll see that our
ES6 modules now has app.js and
package.json file. If you open
up package.json, you'll see that
it just has some information
about it. Why that is important
is because this package that .
json is going to save all of the
references to the packages that
we want to install. Let's go
ahead and try and install a
couple packages. We'll do npm
install slug. That's a slug
library that I like to use if
you ever need slugs. Let's take
a look. npm.im/slug. Just a
library like this where you can
import a slug library and then
you simply just use it. Say "I
love Unicode" and it will return
to you these nice URL-friendly
slugs. We'll say npm install
slug, dash, dash, save. Go ahead
and install that. What that is
doing now...if you open up your
package.json, you will see it
change. There we go. We have
dependencies added. Now we have
slug and also you should see a
node modules folder pop up. You
don't really have to look inside
of here, but what we need to
know is that it installed a
library called slug. I got a
lot of emails with people asking
me, "Why are there so many
folders in here?" These other
folders are just because the
slug has dependencies of its own
and these install in a flat
fashion. Really, don't worry too,
too much about what's inside of
this node modules here. Let's
go ahead install a couple more,
npm install, Lodash and then
let's also install Flickity at
the same time, dash, dash, save
Now, if we go back to our
dependencies you see we have
Flickity, Lodash and slug. If
you're using jQuery or any other
library like this, pretty much
every single JavaScript library
is available on npm. You can
install it like this. I'm going
to close this node modules
folder. One thing I want to
tell you is if you ever
accidentally or on purpose
delete the node modules folder...
I'll often delete the node
modules folder on purpose,
because it is fairly large and I
run out of computer space. If
you ever delete it, you simply
just need to type npm install
once more. What that does is
that it will read your
dependencies in your package at
json file. It will say, "Oh, I
need to download Flickity,
Lodash and slug for it." See how
it's going to get it. You never
need to check this node models
folder and to get...you never
really need to hang on to it
unless you're going on a plane
and need offline access. You can
always type npm install to get
that again. Go ahead and
install a couple more libraries
that...something that you would
use. I want you to try this
with code that you would
probably use every day. If you
use jQuery from day to day, do
npm install, jQuery, dash, dash,
save. I also use one called
Insane which is a really nice
HTML sanitization library, so
npm, install Insane, dash, dash,
save. Now when we head over to
here, you'll see we have Insane
and jQuery being loaded on up.
Now we want to go to our app.js
file, and write some import
statements. Let's import just
one of the methods from Lodash,
so U-N-I-Q from Lodash. We're
going to go over the syntax here.
Essentially what I'm doing is
that I'm importing a named
export. What is that? We'll
learn all about it, but you have
to put curly brackets around it.
Then also let's also import
Insane from the Insane library.
Then let's go over to our
terminal and install one called
JSONP, npm install JSONP, dash,
dash, save. The reason why I
want to show you that is because
we looked at fetch earlier, but
fetch doesn't work with JSONP
API. If you ever want to work
with JSONP API, I can't even say
it, then you need to install
this really nice small package
called JSONP. Maybe let's import
JSONP from JSONP package. Now
we have imported all of these
things. We need to create an
HTML file to load in as app.js.
Create a new file, I'm going to
call it index.html. Give
ourselves some HTML in there.
We're going to call it Js
modules. We give ourselves a
script tag, which will give us...
let's try app.js. Now if I open
that up in my browser and take a
look at my dev tools, we're
going to get this error,
unexpected token import on the
first line. It doesn't know how
to actually handle this import
stuff because that's a one piece
of ES6 that has not yet been
implemented. What we need to do
is we need to use Webpack that's
going to bundle it all together
for us. This a little bit of a
task to get up and running, but
it's generally one thing that
you do at the start of your
project and you're golden. If
you have multiple projects, you
can re-use this set up. We'll go
through it together. You can
find boiler plates online,
however, they are so confusing,
and it's a really overwhelming
space. I really want to make
sure that you understand what's
happening with the module
bundling here with Webpack.
First things that we need to do
is install some dependencies
here. There's a couple. I'm
going to be using Webpack 2
right now because that's going
to come out pretty soon. It's
not yet available. We had to do
npm install Webpack app beta.
The way you can check if you
need that app beta any longer is
you can go to npm.im/webpack,
and then check the version of
Webpack. See the current one for
me is 1.13.1. If that says 2.0
for you, you simply just need to
install Webpack. If it still
says one point something, we
want to install the beta of
Webpack because there's no sense
in really learning Webpack 1
right now when we're trying to
look a little bit future-
friendly here. Webpack app beta,
and we'll say dash, dash, save,
dev. The reason why we're
saying dash, dash, save, dev
instead of just dash, dash, save
is because this is just a tool
for building it. It's not part
of our application. It's just a
development tool. We're going
to go and install that. Let's
head over to our package at JSON.
We should see a secondary item
being added here called dev
dependencies. There we go.
Popped up, Webpack, this one is
beta 15, it will probably a more
recent version when you actually
get around to doing the series.
Then we also need a couple
things that's going to help us
convert our code to ES5. Now we
haven't talked about Babel, but
the long and short of it right
now is that it will take your
ES6 code and convert it to the
equivalent ES5 code and make it
work in all of the browsers. We
will go much more into it, but
this is the point when we
actually integrate Babel into
our build system so that it will
work on all of our browsers. We
need to install a whole bunch of
Babel add-ons and I've included
the instructions on ES6 module
instructions so you don't have
to type it every single time. We
already did Webpack install app
beta. We also need this thing
called a Babel loader, we need
the Babel core, and then we need
this thing, Babel preset ES2015
Native modules. What that does
is it's going to convert all of
our code from ES6 or ES2015 down
to ES5, but this Native modules
version is going to skip
converting them to this older
module version called common Js,
because Webpack 2 is able to
handle Native modules. Now, if
top of your head just blew off
after everything I said don't
worry about it. You'll catch on
to it. Just take this one npm
install line, pop it into here,
and let that install. You can
check if it worked if you go to
your package at JSON and you see
your dev dependencies is now
Babel core, loader, preset and
Webpack all installed. Finally,
we need to create a Webpack file
that's actually going to hold
all the config for this, so we
will say touch, Webpack, dot,
config, dot Js and you can open
that up and we need to import
Webpack. Const Webpack equals
require Webpack. Now you might
be saying, "Why are we using
require here." That's common Js
if you ever heard of that, but
the problem here is that our
Webpack config actually isn't
going to use ES6 imports because
node doesn't support that just
yet. Then we will also need a
variable for the environment and
this is going to help us do
production builds and
development builds and the
production builds will be much
smaller. So it's Const node in
equals. All right, now what we
need to do is create a module
dot exports and that is going to
be an object and inside of this
module exports we have a couple
things. We have a dev tool,
which is going to give us
something called source maps,
source dash map. We have an
entry point. So with web pack
you have an entry point it
essentially says where do you
want to start your application.
We are going to start in app.js.
You see the file name is app.js,
and then the output is where do
you wish for it to go. File name
is going to be, I'm going to
make a folder called Build, and
make it called bundle.js. You
might see I already have it here,
that's because I made it once to
test it for the screen cast.
Then we have a module inside of
here which has a loaders array.
Loaders are essentially how
should I handle specific types
of files because Webpack is just
a beast. You can use it for
absolutely everything. It can
pretty much do everything under
the sun. One of the loaders
that we are going to do is we
are going to take all of our
JavaScript files and we are
going to run it through Babel
with our specific plug-ins. The
first loader is going to be an
object and the way that you tell
it the entry point is that if it
is a .js file. We'll say test
for a bit of a funky
here .js and it
ends with Js, by the way if you
don't feel like typing this you
can just scroll on to ES6 module
instructions and just copy and
paste this entire thing. If
you'd like to hear me explain it
all the way through then stick
around. We want to exclude the
node modules directory. We don't
want it to run against the
entire node modules directory.
The loader that we are going to
run this JavaScript file through
is Babel or Babel dash core.
That's going to convert it all
to ES5 and then there is a query
which will allow us to set some
presets with JavaScript. We want
the ES2015 dash native dash
modules. Again the reason I am
using Native modules here is
because Webpack 2 doesn't need
them converted to common Js
files. Webpack 2 knows how to
handle ES6 modules, which is
really, really nice. So, that
is my module up and running. The
final is, let's go down here, we
need some plug-ins that are
going to actually handle that.
Plug-ins, the plug-ins, there is
going to be a couple of them
right here. Let's just leave
comments. So like, Uglify Js,
that's just going to compress
our JavaScript so it is nice and
small. Then we have the
environment plug-in which will
set the actual environment
inside of that. Uglify Js is
new Webpack.optimize.uglify
Js plug-in. That takes the
object of Uglify JS properties
compress is going to be warnings.
Output is going to have comments
false and source maps is going
to be true. That's the Webpack
1 and then we have this
environment plug-in, which is
another new webpack.define plug
in. That will take an object,
process is the node mv. Going to
be set to JSON.Stringify the
node and variable we have
created there. Essentially what
that does is it passes the
environment variable to this
code and plug-ins like Uglify
are going to be able to know if
they should remove certain
things or not depending on what
environment we are actually in.
Lets just do a quick look over.
Looks like I forgot a comma
there. Any other errors? Nope.
Looking pretty good. Third step
what we want to do in order to
run Webpack we need to run it.
We could run it from the command
line. We could install Webpack
globally. An even nicer way is
to use what is called and npm
script. If you head on over to
your package.json file and
scroll up to where it says
scripts, you will see that we
have only one that's called "
Test." You can delete that
that's for running tests. So
delete that entirely. We are
going to create a script called
Build and that Build is going to
be set to the command Webpack
and we are going to pass it just
two flags. Progress and watch.
Now, without having to globally
install Webpack we should be
able to say npm, run, build. We
say Run and Build is the name of
the actual script that we have
here. Let's run it and see if we
have any errors, we might.
Beautiful! So what happened
here is that it created us a
Build file which is bundle.js.
One thing is I'm not seeing my
source map show up. Let me
double check my Webpack config.
I forgot a capital M on the
Uglify so Uglify Js was
stripping them back out. So if I
quit that and rerun npm run
build, it then kick outs a nice
tidy bundle as well as a source
map for us. If we go to our
index.html, change this app.js
to _build/bundle.js. Why?
Because it's _build bundle.js.
If we go to our app.js and try
to use these things, so let's
just say, const ages = 1, 1, 4,
52, 12, 4. I have these ages
here, and I want to just get the
unique versions of them. Let's
just say, console.log unique
ages. That should work. See how
when I hit save, it reruns this
Webpack bundle here? If we open
up our index.html in our browser
and open up our console here,
you now see unique array. It
tells us that we wrote that on
app.js, on line 7. That was a
very basic getting up-and-
running with Webpack. I know it
was a little bit of a slog to
get through some of that. It's
the tooling is a little bit
tough right now, but if you get
the hang of it, it's definitely
worth implementing into your
workflow.